[Music]
there is no elevator to success you've
got to take the stairs if you find
meaning in quotes like this put them
right up where you will see them every
day here are another 13 tips to get
started ask why if we don't know why we
are doing it then we don't see a point
whether we want to make a career change
the world or prove some idiots wrong
these are all great reasons to get going
simon Sinek spoke of the Golden Circle
first ask why then how and what if you
don't have a purpose right now pick up a
skill that helps you once you do like
reading fast learning how to learn or
public speaking know about the
dunning-kruger effect the theory
describes that many of us are too
confident when we learn something new
once we actually start learning we
realize how difficult it is and how
incompetent we are as a result our
motivation drops and many of us quit the
trick to success is to keep going anyway
once we master an area our confidence
returns look for feedback marathon
runners know that encouraging spectators
can make a massive difference on the
last meters feedback is a strong force
so deliberately seek it one way just ask
for advice most people love giving it it
makes them feel smart entrepreneurs who
look for investors say ask for money
you'll get advice ask for advice you'll
get money articulate your values in one
experiment at the beginning of the new
school year 7th graders had to pick a
personal value such as being good at
school making friends or music then they
spent 15 minutes writing down why this
matter to them to remind them the
process was repeated every two to four
months within two years most week
students or 10% increase in all grades a
year later the experiment was repeated
this time the value being good as school
was not even available the surprising
truth
again all grades got better remind
yourself what you really care about get
a mentor look for charismatic people you
can look up to by following your mentor
we can find inspiration get new ideas
maybe even find purpose you might be
able to find them around the block for a
list of our favorite mentors check our
website or the descriptions below don't
make excuses to see if you do
Bernard Roth from the Stanford's D
school teaches to reframe problems by
asking yourself this particular question
what would it do for me if I had already
solved the problem for example if you
think you're fat then ask yourself what
would it do for me if I would lose
weight if the answer is that you would
ask that cute girl out on a date then
forget about losing weight and ask her
out on a date prime yourself Canadian
researchers observed that salesmen in
call centers can be 50 percent more
successful when they see pictures that
represent success while making their
calls the effect is called priming most
of us become smarter in a library
because we tend to be more thoughtful
and many feel more successful when we
dress well stand up straight with our
arms out and our heads held high make
bets make your life a game and take bets
groups of pretty people do that all over
the world to lose weight the one who
can't lose two kilos in six weeks has to
buy cupcakes for everyone but it also
works for reading books or challenging
yourself to ask a girl out for dinner
track your record records show us where
we are coming from they indicate
progress good music teachers record the
students first lesson one year later
they show their students what they
recorded most are amazed how much they
progressed as Nelson Mandela said it
always seems impossible until it's done
starts more when we put effort into
something and we succeed we are
motivated to continue
it's a self-reinforcing circle if we aim
too high right at the beginning it's
likely that we will fail this can lead
to frustration and we might stop before
we even get started want to learn how to
sing start with five minutes every
morning surround yourself with positive
people author Jim Rohn wrote that we are
the average of the five people we spend
the most time with to get motivated
spend time with positive people that
have a growth mindset negative people
often have a problem for every solution
get context if you need to study maps
but your passion is sports and cooking
analyze your favorite football player
find out how many kilometers he runs and
how many goals he scores on average then
calculate calories and make a healthy
meal that would give him enough energy
to score two goals in one game help
others if they succeed you get positive
energy back one trick to motivate others
is to use purpose explain why things
matter paint a picture of their possible
future then engage them to take
responsibility last give them the right
tools and feedback to help them succeed
leadership coach Steve Radcliffe calls
it future engage deliver establish
discipline as motivation can come and go
discipline will stay and watch you like
a hawk one way to get disciplined is to
set a fixed time to do something and
then make sure you always do it no
matter what for example work out every
morning for 20 minutes right before
breakfast over time it will become a
habit and you don't even need motivation
if you have to do something important or
make a big decision
switch off YouTube right now and do it
as internet activist Aaron Swartz asked
what is the most important thing you
could be working on right now and if you
aren't working on that why aren't you
you
if you like our videos and want to
support our channel visit us at
patreon.com slash sprouts and see if you
want to donate just $1 with your support
we plan to create many more minute
videos about learning and education
you